>>> I'M A BOSS.
I'M --
>> ANNA DELVEY GETS WHATEVER SHE
WANTS.
>> YOUR MONEY IS COMING.
WHY COULDN'T YOU JUST LISTEN?
>> HEY, ANDREW.
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT SANDWICH?
>> OH, THEY'RE JUST OUT IN THE
WRITER'S ROOM.
>> OH, GREAT, I'M STARVING.
>> OH, THIS WAS ACTUALLY THE
LAST ONE.
>> OH.
OKAY.
♪♪
>> I'M A BOSS!
>> ANDREW, WAIT.
THAT'S ACTUALLY MY SANDWICH.
>> WHAT IS THAT VOICE?
>> MY SANDWICH IS IN YOUR MOUTH.
GIVE ME MY SANDWICH.
>> OKAY.
YEAH.
SORRY.
I DIDN'T KNOW.
♪♪
♪ I'M A BOSS-ASS BITCH ♪
♪ I'M A BOSS-ASS ♪♪
>> THIS FOOD IS LIKE BASIC, YOU
KNOW.
CHIPS ARE BROKE-ASS.
WE NEED SOMETHING MORE
EXCLUSIVE.
MORE VIP.
LIKE NOBU.
RUN THIS ON MY CARD.
>> THIS IS A METRO CARD.
>> RUN IT AGAIN!
HEY, LITTLE BOY.
LORNE SAYS THAT'S MY COUCH NOW.
>> LORNE SAID THAT?
'CAUSE I BROUGHT THIS FROM MY
HOME.
>> I ASSURE YOU HIS TEXT IS ON
THE WAY.
HE'S IN THE HAMPTONS RIGHT NOW.
RECEPTION IS VERY BAD.
VERY VIP.
>> THAT DOES SOUND LIKE LORNE.
>> MY FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> LORNE SAYS I'LL DO BANNON
NOW.
>> HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING TO ME.
>> TEXT IS ON THE WAY.
GIVE ME YOUR TEETH.
LORNE SAYS I'LL HOST UPDATE NOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, BYE.
>> I STILL DIDN'T GET A CARD.
>> YOU'RE BEING SO DRAMATIC.
THE WIRE TRANSFER'S ON THE WAY.
>> OH, COOL.
OYSTERS.
>> WHAT'RE YOU WEARING?
YOU LOOK PARKED.
>> I LOOK WHAT, NOW?
>> PAAAH.
>> TALL?
>> HAAAR.
>> WHAT?
>> POOR.
>> POOR?
>> YES.
I LOVED YOU IN "DUNE," BY THE
WAY.
>> THANKS.
>> SAY HI TO TIMOTHEE CHALAMET.
FROM NOW ON, MY COSTUME --
>> HEY, CHLOE.
ANY UPDATE ON THAT WIRE
TRANSFER?
I'M IN REALLY DEEP.
>> I DO NOT HAVE TIME FOR THIS!
I DO NOT HAVE TIME FOR YOU!
I'M A MASTERPIECE, BITCHES!
>> OKAY.
>> I CAN PAY.
I CAN PAY.
I'M SORRY.
>> CHLOE.
COME ON.
THERE YOU GO.
>> I CAN PAY.
>> CHLOE.
I CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE, YOU'VE
BEEN DELVEYING EVERYONE TODAY.
>> I CAN PAY.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS.
THE HAIR, THE GLASSES, THE
RUSSIAN ACCENT THAT'S ALSO
GERMAN.
YOU'VE JUST GOT TO BE CONFIDENT.
YOU KNOW?
THE REAL DELVEY IS INSIDE YOU.
AND HAS BEEN ALL ALONG.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M SORRY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
I'M JUST GLAD I STOPPED THIS
BEFORE ANYONE GOT HURT AND THERE
WERE ANY REAL CONSEQUENCES.
>> WELL, I GUESS I WON'T BE
NEEDING THESE ANYMORE.
BYE, KATE.
>> BYE.
>> THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE DELVEY
AROUND HERE.
VERY VIP.